we don't really play games with our
parents
oh game playing um probably maybe once a
month video games i usually i'm like no
i haven't really played anything since
the early 90s once a week
[Music]
family learning let me think everything
when parents and kids get together to
share experiences and explore the world
together my name is cinema han i'm an
associate professor of educational
technology and learning sciences at cal
state san marcos
my gaming skills are average
sorry i can't i just want to make sure
that i can get some moves out of the
scale
my current work is inspired by my
experience as a child two parents are
working long hours they didn't have
enough energy and time to play with me
and my brother and we didn't really get
to spend time together
i try to play with my
son
as much as i can
i value playing games oh
yes yes
so for example here
we're exploring a farm
and we're interacting with animals
and my son is learning
what sound each animal makes what does
the sheep say
engaging in play is important
whether it is
digital or non-digital play
we invite parents and kids to play
together we're fortunate to have
alienware provide gaming laptops for our
families
what i find really interesting with play
to connect it helps families grow these
shared values together hey cinema how's
it going it's going well how are you i'm
doing well did everything show up yes we
have the laptops they're ready to go i
believe i am making positive impact
through video games one of the problems
that i see is video games are framed as
a context of conflict between parents
and kids what i'm trying to do is to
show parents and kids that video games
could be a context for togetherness
collaboration
problem solving hello everyone welcome
to our play to connect event
thank you for coming we're really
excited to have you here
[Music]
oh my gosh you're stopping the waterfall
all right we're gonna have parents and
kids switch now you need to start
capturing the animals and into space
[Music]
all right let's try to plant seeds and
see what happens what is happening i
have a plan what are we gonna do i have
to
[Music]
now it's the other way around a few
times i did big mistakes like flooded or
our corn fields
did you enjoy the challenges especially
the chicken farm we made
why does it have a skeleton in it it's a
lot more fun than i thought it was
really interesting watching him at work
there's just more value here than i
think i had imagined that it could be
really good quality time and i'm
surprised at how patient he was with me
you liked me doing it and then you were
telling me good job
that was cool it's really important that
we shift the trend around video games
and families
and really start thinking about video
games
in terms of their potential to
contribute to our lives
yeah that's the pig where's the thing
[Music]